hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
I'm chief UN weapons inspector Dave
Reuben I've got two great guests with me
Aaron Foley and jr. Jackson and we got a
lot to get to so let's do it okay today
is the 12th anniversary of the 9/11
terror attacks I'm a lifetime New York
resident I was in New York City twelve
years ago and I've I just moved out of
New York so this is my first 9/11 not
being there and obviously it was it was
the worst terrorist attack we've had in
the United States and there's been all
sorts of repercussions that we've been
dealing with since then including war
and NSA and Patriot Act and all kinds of
stuff just this morning I was watching
MSNBC was showing NBC's live footage and
it's really incredible how quickly you
can just go back to that place that we
were at twelve years ago it's really
it's something else so first off the the
Freedom Tower is being built right now
and it's actually almost complete let's
take a look at the at the image because
it's pretty it's pretty spectacular so
you know the city is coming back twelve
years later the city seems to be coming
back and and the country seems to be
coming back and healing but as I said a
lot of things have changed since then so
I know this isn't the funnest topic that
we can jump off to but how do you guys
feel about the whole thing
twelve years later does the feelings and
the rawness of it and everything else
sort of disappear as as time goes on
well I was just I lived in New York as
well you know during that time for for
most of my life and when you see the
footage this morning I put it on and
then I had to turn it off because it's
12 years but it just feels like
yesterday I remember you know step by
step where I was coming off the subway
you hear you know plane hit the world
our we're trade and and you just think
it's like a bumper like you know so much
happens in New York it's like everything
all day is so crazy in the news and
whatever you don't even think anything
of it you know what I mean you're like
oh God probably a 2-seater hits aside
but you know I mean you and then by the
time I got upstairs I was working this
day job right by the
by the UN and then you're like a second
plant it was just literally when you see
the footage it's like it happened
yesterday it you go right back to that
because you think New York is impervious
to like absolutely anything from having
to it and uh and then it was just
admitted after minute just absolute like
the worst news imaginable and then I
remember I was on forty forty third and
first Street and you I didn't know where
to go like my sister was in Brooklyn
teaching so I'm like okay she's okay my
other sister was at the she's a social
worker she was at the Armory building
then they started bringing in the army
into the armory building and there's a
women's shelter and in the ground floor
of that building and she was like the
army is rolling in with like a tank and
it was just it was the craziest moment
of like you didn't know where to go
yeah as you were mentioning know so he
said a brought up memories as if it was
yesterday even it was twelve years ago
so on March 17th because we talked about
of course every year on the anniversary
on March 17th asking the both of you do
you feel like you forget sometimes the
the magnitude because you're not
thinking about it specifically but now
things like what happened on the MSNBC
this morning they do they come back and
give us a stark reminder about what
happened and now we have to reflect on
what our world has become because of it
so do you mean do you forget about it on
just the average yeah even when it's
getting with the beginning of September
you think ten days from now you know you
start to think about really fond
memories of well I mean I remember one
of the things that struck me when I was
watching the coverage today was the
feeling there was like a two-hour
feeling once the planes hit and then
they realized that the the other one hit
the Pentagon that actually there was
going to be a mass like it seemed like
the whole country was crumbling at once
remember then then a few hours later we
realized how horrible it was but that
the country institutions of the country
were still gonna exist so I think there
are certain things that
are you and bringing back to that where
were you I was I was a junior in school
at USC area in LA so I was and I
remember I was at my I was rented a
house with a couple roommates and we did
have a TV in my room
but I always had the radio on at night
just playing around the music just cuz I
need noise I already lived by three
hospitals so that wasn't enough noise
already but so I I kind of groggily woke
up and you know it's we have were three
hours behind all this all this went down
with eight nine in the morning seven
yeah nine yeah first night right before
9:00 the second one fell at 10:00
yes it's I'm waking up at 6:30 7 o'clock
and the second one I didn't see the
first one I was still asleep when that
happened so uh my roommates were this
happy wouldn't live cable stuff so I
just had the radio on and my roommate
bus in he goes do you hear what's going
on and I'm like what like what's going
on he goes your radio was talking about
like of course everything is preempted
and everyone was talking about so we
didn't have cable and I was like I gotta
get to some cable news something that's
happening 24/7 and I rushed over to a
friend's place that was actually near
campus and sat there all day I obviously
had class it was a Tuesday at class and
I was thinking there's absolutely no way
I'm going to class one of the classes
was one of those ones
there's not many collegiate classes that
take attendance and in market and
remember it as if you're in high school
yeah this was one of them and I said you
know what whatever professor so-and-so
is gonna have to be upset at me today
because I'm not going anywhere you know
and it was one of things that crossed
your mind because people were thinking
some people did go to class they're like
oh other side of the country and other
people thinking what if it could happen
here I didn't think that I'm just
thinking we need to figure out what's
going on with the country this is a
collective thing now this isn't just
something to happen where are there was
there was a you know a mass shooting in
another city and like all that's
contained when nobody really knows how
this is gonna affect us and obviously
told me that it still does